she's one of Spain's leading ladies
please welcome Penelope Cruz
I'm here to present tonight's award for
best achievement in costume design the
nominees are the history and traditions
of ancient China were the inspirations
for the colorful designs of nominee Qing
Yi and his memorable costumes for
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon the
humorous drawings of dr. Seuss were
adapted for the screen by nominee Rita
Riya who created the water for the
Grinch and the good people of who-ville
the power glory and opulence of the
Roman Empire provided the things for the
Magnificent costumes designed by nominee
John T aids for gladiator in 102
Dalmatians nominee Anthony Powell not
only saw spots but plenty of color for
his flashy costume creations in this
second tale of keen and kept Romania and
in quills Jacqueline West costumes
reached back in time to evoke the dark
period of the French Revolution and the
final days of the Marquis de sel
and the Oscar goes to Jen th for
gladiator
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for chantiers
Thank You Academy
Thank You DreamWorks Thank You
waterparks
Branko Lustig Terry Needham a huge thank
you to Ridley Scott for his vision and
his incredible inspiration but this
doesn't belong to me alone it belongs to
a huge costume crew who worked so hard
in Malta and Morocco and in the UK it
belongs to the armor makers it belongs
to the costume makers to the jewelry
Footwear creators and the costume
breakers I couldn't have done it without
these people without Vanessa Jones
without my husband Tony Dixon without
Jake Scott and I couldn't have done it
without rosemary burrows Annie Hadley
and Sammy Howard thank you
by the way Penelope Cruz had starred in
such movies as live flesh woman on top
and has just finished a movie called
below and now here to erase that imagery
from your mind is the president of the
Academy Bob raining
sit thank you
you'll be hearing those words a lot
tonight from some extremely grateful
people including me as I finished my
fifth and final year as president of the
Academy I'd like this thanks very much
I'd like to say a brief thank you to
more than 6,000 Academy members and do
our Board of Governors for allowing me
to serve them it's been an honor and
frankly a great thrill for 73 years the
Academy is endeavored to advance the
Arts and Sciences of motion pictures and
to recognize outstanding achievements in
filmmaking by conferring our golden
Oscar filmmakers our extraordinary
artists based all around the world and
supply that world with its most glorious
and powerful art form let's use that
power with a high and your main sense of
purpose and for some of you who've
fallen a little short of that mark
you'll be given another chance between
now and the end of my term I'll be
considering some presidential pardons
thank you last year's Oscar winner for
her role and Girl Interrupted returns to
deliver one this year Angelina Jolie